at this doctor Berg I want to talk about
this question that keeps coming up I
always ask people what is the best
source of potassium and everyone says
bananas bananas are the worst source of
potassium I mean you have to consume 12
bananas to get your daily amount of
potassium because typically banana has
maybe three to four hundred milligrams
and the normal amounts that you need are
close to forty seven hundred forty seven
hundred so let's kind of go through
first of all what what potassium
deficiencies will create and then I'll
show you some other things on that let
me just give you access to this right
here okay potassium potassium is a
physiological relaxer it helps a lot of
things but but let me just kind of give
you the the key areas that potassium
will help number one blood pressure
why because potassium gets rid of excess
sodium to help balance the potassium
sodium ratio because sodium tends to
retain fluid increasing flow to tension
and blood pressure so potassium will
lower the blood pressure the metabolism
of protein so if you're consumed if
you're a meat-eater and you don't eat a
lot of vegetables you won't be able to
metabolize that protein so I'm talking
about the hairs nail skin the tissues
the structures the tendons the ligaments
you need potassium to be able to create
proteins on your body it controls blood
sugar so you know that in order to store
blood sugar in your liver and your
muscles you need potassium so without
potassium you're going to crave sweets
and sugar like crazy and your blood
Sugar's will will be more erratic so by
taking more potassium you can help
stabilize blood sugars potassium is a
main electrolyte which helps heart
function so you need it for the heart to
function to avoid getting Pappa tations
arrhythmias things like that potassium
is a relaxer so it helps you sleep at
night
recovery it helps prevent kidney stones
but see most people don't even consume
the close to the normal amount that you
need per day you need 47 out of
milligrams that would be about seven to
ten cups of salad per day so if you buy
one of those big plastic containers of
salad they usually come in like ounces
so you have like I don't know I think
it's like 18 ounces for a real big one
that's 18 cups so you would need to
consume half of that every single day to
get your potassium that's how I get mine
through a lot of salads but there are
other vegetables that you can consume
potassium I'm going to show you those
right now okay so number one beet greens
has 1300 milligrams that's crazy high
now when you go to the grocery store you
see you could you could buy beats right
you know those are but they have these
big stems with the leaves that would be
big greens very few people consume those
but if you put those in your salad you
will get a lot of potassium and it's
also good for the gallbladder - Swiss
chard but very very bitter vegetable
I suggest saute it may put in your salad
you can juice it you can blend it so
that has 960 milligrams per cup avocados
almost 900 milligrams per avvocato a
medium amount I consume an avocado a day
in the morning when I have my eggs 4x I
throw avocados on there because I like
that I love avocados I don't like them
ripe though I don't like them too raw or
unripe that Roe okay so because they're
always wrong you're not going to cook
them
winter squash has a ton is like almost
900 spinach has 838 milligrams
sweet potato potato has a lot but I
wouldn't recommend consuming those
unless you're not trying to worry about
weight and because those can be kind of
starchy and look at bananas 3x 400
that's for a big banana kind of a medium
size
small one would be 300 so you can see
right there that bananas are not the
best source of potassium and I think
that's one of the myths out there now
here's the thing um I like to get my
potassium from vegetables not fruit
because fruit has a little bit too much
sugar
so the other thing is that when you eat
protein like meats and things it doesn't
really have a lot of potassium so you
must eat more salad and vegetables we
need a balance of potassium and sodium
sodium we need about a thousand
milligrams potassium we need about four
point seven more the ratio is of about
one to four one point actually one to
four point seven so I want to give it to
technical but the point is that from
every thousand milligrams of sodium you
need that much potassium so what a lot
of people will do is to lower their
sodium intake that's not very smart
because you need sodium for energy for
your adrenals for a lot of things but
you want it in sea salt but the thing to
do is not to lower sodium but to
increase potassium so you have the
ratios because if you ever notice that
when you go home at night you might
crave the toss up like sweets right and
then you crave salt and then sweet and
then salt you're trying to get
electrolytes from this food because your
body your adrenal glands are drained and
you're tired so a much better way would
be to consume a large huge green salad
and then have something salty that would
really solve the problem so I just want
to create a little video on this myth
and I hope you got a couple tips so
start increasing your intake of
potassium and I will see you in the next
video